hello and welcome to this video playing
I am live from the Netherlands I think
so we get them get a Sicilian here the
accelerated dragon and maroc see but at
least it's something we have experienced
so let's see what he what he what he is
doing mmm look see what I believe yeah
och yeah this is a well-known line that
I have had quite quite a bit in in blitz
chess this is some line where black is
believed to be only marginally worse and
he plays it all right but I have to say
it's been a while since I've checked it
there is some f5 counterplay that black
is so having on the agenda yeah here we
here here we go f5 okay I think I'm
going to take it and white quite often
goes g-form in this kind of this kind of
this line I wonder if this is the
correct way to do it here I also kind of
like f1 bishop f3 I just wonder there
might be ideas here tactical ideas
him to activate his pieces okay they do
Koji for almost all the time and this
this kind of structure but we'll see
putting the bishop to f3 mmm doesn't
look that bad if you if you ask me maybe
you can just take c3 play 94 for for
those opposite colored bishops but it
looks am a little bit okay it looks like
a pretty defensive kind of setup cop
maybe it's not bad so g4 looks like the
way to go yeah let's grab space for f5
with this one hmm it isn't this a little
bit better than me I mean my king is
more active here and
Kingda 45 not show him rookie ones also
an option whoopsie one simply and I
don't I don't quite know actually we're
going to deform and to move the bishop
no and I can actually take the pawn what
is the most precise here maybe it's to
draw much anyway let's it's possible it
is it really possible but then stop kind
of a tree chair if there is something
interesting going on I can also play
Bishop to b6 sorry I know it is doing
much though Toby not narrowed the Ada
and the OSS rook to e3 which I want to
answer with King f4
doesn't help energy for now probably
this is just equal
yeah that's very equal and do I have
something that I can try I really if I
trunk mmm why wasn't he able to capture
it don't don't quite see why that was
the problem
anyway if I take you form no it's still
it's still pretty much nothing I cannot
take before him yeah it wasn't important
import the time money I have the F the H
cornered it cannot be all that grade it
takes you for 50 seconds
just push it back fire can I mean okay
here be sure to you for years to play
and then we have a draw can i connect
place all the women let me let me try a
little something I mean I can certainly
put the pawn to h6 without risking
anything
I cannot do anything just to draw draw
our third
clock this is a way to maybe use idea
with a silly pre-move let's roll the
position I should have taken channel 4
check check check
small mate mmm it's nice Jack um okay I
often try things he cooks positions
where there's nothing to try yeah that
was probably just a little bit too
little here this this thing I mean I'm a
little bit better here it doesn't seem
to really mean that much am The King and
so on there should be six yeses of me
that I did consider briefly but then
that seemed to natural for me to not
play it but the likelihood of a draw is
probably extremely high here he is six i
didn't i didn't think about it hi I
wasn't pramod it was a bit weird that he
didn't take it yeah I mean he could have
just taken it but um yeah so I could
have taken this I was thinking this is
not great this rational irritated me but
I can go here which I forgot about I'm
just a poor now I mean okay hey it's a
draw still here but I didn't didn't see
that I could take it yeah and here we
just have a complete draw okay we are
considering the time I should prolong
take the girl here and not not continue
we should come whatever I mean I can
basically never lose the position from a
position point of view but the time chat
thing I always resource-rich this dead
ending
hmm Jim I probably should play it
differently oh I forgot to switch on the
analysis but I can assure you it never
left the area of 0.3 or something ok
guys thanks for watching